emmanuel macron un nouvel interlocuteur
à washington après trois ans et demi de
relation diplomatique mouvementé marqué
par le retrait de donald trump de
nombreux traités internationaux
l'arrivée de joe biden laisse envisager
une normalisation des échanges
diplomatiques une nouvelle stratégie qui
devrait permettre de faire renaître le
multilatéralisme
une bonne nouvelle pour emmanuel macron
qui a toujours cherché à maintenir le
dialogue entre les puissances mondiales
symbole de cette réconciliation le
retour de washington dans l'accord de
paris sur le climat qui a été confirmé
par joe biden le 4 novembre date à
laquelle les états unis l'ont
officiellement quitté aujourd'hui
l'administration trump a officiellement
quitté l'accord de paris sur le climat
et dans exactement soixante dix sept
jours une administration bayh dole le
rejoindra mais l'élection du démocrate
joe biden ne signifie pas pour autant
des engagements massifs des états unis
sur l'ensemble de la scène mondiale
car le retrait américain du moyen-orient
et d'europe n'a pas commencé avec donald
trump mais bien avec barack obama et son
vice président d'alors un certain joe
biden une position qui pourrait poser
problème à paris qui compte sur le
soutien de la maison blanche dans sa
lutte contre le terrorisme
joe biden va renouveler les alliances
avec les français il va être aimable et
poli comme le fut barack obama avec nous
mais comme lui il y à fort à parier
qu'il ne tiendra aucun compte de nos
opinions
l'arrivée de joe biden au pouvoir
pourrait même affaiblir l'influencé des
manuels macro à l'international
nucléaire iranien dialogue avec la
russie
le président français a réussi à tirer
son épingle du jeu sur l'échiquier
mondial
nouvellement élu joe biden va sans doute
vouloir redonner aux etats unis son rôle
de médiateur dans les grands dossiers
internationaux au détriment des manuels
macro